[Music]  what's your name Laura sunny Croft  Laura your father's gone  you can pick up where he left off I see  so much of him in you  brilliant hello sprout if you're  listening to this then I must be dead  I found something a tool called the  mother of death if Trinity succeeds our  world is in danger promise me you will  stop I promise I think I know where my  dad went that's right in the middle of  the devil sea it'll be an adventure  death isn't a hunter than adventure  [Music]  [Music]  you shouldn't have come here but I'm  glad that you did  [Music]  what I know about my father now I see  the lightness the recklessness close the  to once and for the fate of humanity is  now in your hands  [Music]  don't be too careful these days the  world has gone bloody mad I'll take two  you